I'm Laura Ingram this is Ingram angle on
a very busy Tuesday just seven weeks
before the midterms if you can believe
it
the last gasps that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
look in all seriousness folks that's how
Biden speaks right 49 days to go before
the midterms and the Democrats they have
so much to be proud of
8.3 percent is the year over year number
coming in hotter than expected and
hotter than a lot of economists a lot of
people on this panel thought it was
going to come in since middle of last
year we've seen that inflation is going
up faster than wages that means that if
you adjust paychecks for inflation
they're actually shrinking robberies and
property crimes are rising robbery has
jumped 19 this crime is on the rise
across the nation
heck of a job Joey but at least the
Democrats always had the pandemic to
help them hold on to power right well
until Biden messed that up on 60 Minutes
that is
a pandemic is over we still have a
problem with covet we're still doing a
lot of work on it uh it's but the
pandemic is over if you notice no one's
wearing masks everybody seems to be in
pretty good shape
the branch covidians at the White House
they're beside themselves because if the
pandemic is truly over so is the
president's federal health emergency and
that brings us to another Biden walk
back
the White House Now clarifying President
Biden's response the White House rushed
to clarify White House has to put out a
statement after the press conference
we are not where we need to be if we're
going to be able to quote live with the
virus is the pandemic over what the
president's reflecting is the fact that
we've made tremendous progress against
covet 19. but he also said you know we
have more work to do on coven we need
people to take that vaccine
well that man is the definition of
smarmy now at this point trying to sell
this vaccine and the new booster it's
like trying to sell an eight-track tape
player okay nobody wants one anymore
but that's not going to stop the
Washington Post from selling the covet
cult Mantra and gently correcting Biden
writing the pandemic has shifted and
normalcy has returned in many ways but
it is not over Mr Biden has not ended
the official pandemic emergency when the
official emergency ends some 15 million
will lose Medicaid coverage the reason
for the student loan repayment pause
will end all this policy transition must
not be done carelessly or hastily two
and a half years counts as hasty for the
Washington Post
I got it now they don't ever want it to
end because more emergencies equal more
government dependency more government
spending
without ever having to go through
Congress by the way which is you know
the big Defenders of democracy
anyone with a brain knows that Biden's
coveted crutch whether they know it or
not it's gone
and now all Democrats have to offer is a
lousy economy an open border and rampant
crime
and regular Americans who actually pay
their own bills they're beginning to
place the blame where it properly lies
with the Democrats the Senate and
gubernatorial races are starting to lean
closer to the Republicans in Georgia
Herschel Walker is now up over Rafael
Warnock and new polling is bad news for
the left-wing supposed savior in Georgia
Stacy Abrams
and Ron Johnson will beat the radical
pro-criminal candidate Mandela Barnes
what a nightmare he is in Wisconsin a
new Emerson poll has Johnson now Up by
Four Points Mandela is just a hardcore
leftist
Ella Barnes thinks the founding of
America was awful and our national parks
are racist he supported a 20 increase in
the gas tax and 70 percent top income
tax rate and the Dela Barnes oppose the
school choice but wants to teach your
children critical race Theory
yikes and in Nevada a state once thought
to be solidly blue well it's turning out
not to be Catherine Cortez masto a
liberal who never cared about the border
and now pretends to is getting a serious
Challenge from Republican Adam laxalt
now I bet a sizable sum of money on the
fact that the Democrats their own
internal polling it's telling them that
they're on track to lose the Senate
it isn't even October yet though so
don't get all excited because they're
not going to go down without a pathetic
last-ditch effort to turn the tide
now with the queen buried and the bad
economic news piling up of course like
clockwork the January 6 committee
reconvenes next week so expect more of
the same old video of the Capitol window
being smashed and people scaling the
walls you'll have a lot more of those
furrowed brow expressions from the
committee members aren't you tired of
those
now if only Democrats cared as much
about the pain suffered by their own
constituents devastated by Soaring bills
violent crime and Fentanyl pouring
across the open border
millions of non-citizens have invaded
our country under Biden but Democrats
aren't interested in analyzing that
video in the next 49 days no way
so desperation it makes people do crazy
things
expect Democrat messaging over the next
several weeks to get nuttier and more
extreme and their tactics to be even
more anti-democratic
they're going to work with their social
media proxies to censor anyone who
opposes them
and that's through line of hate never
fully goes away
it only hides and when given any Oxygen
it comes out from under the rocks
in the last few years has been given
much too much oxygen in our politics
in our media and on the internet
and of course they're going to cry
racism at every turn
have determined that domestic terrorism
rooted in white supremacy
as the greatest terrorist threat my dad
would say if your silence is complicity
they're going to villainize parents and
Christians as dumb bigots
people on the local level at affected
school board meetings they won't forget
the Maga
Republicans descending on their school
board meetings after January 6. it was a
coordinated attack happening across the
country
they're going to use the doj the FBI and
every other branch of government to
harass effective political adversaries
that search was a premises located in
Florida belonging to the former
president I personally approved the
decision to seek a search warrant in
this matter
and when that doesn't work
ocean by set
s on conservative donors
now you may ask how's this going to
happen well if they had their druthers
they would force super Pacs or issue
advocacy groups to divulge their donor
lists Biden's motives are so altruistic
though I believe sunlight is the best
disinfectant there's much too much money
that flows in the shadows to influence
our elections it's called Dark money
it's called Dark money oh now that's a
problem he didn't think it was a problem
in 2020 when 174 million dollars flooded
the election from his Anonymous
supporters or six times the 25 million
Trump got
Biden couldn't even pretend to hide his
ultimate objective today
and here's just one recent example
conservative activists who spent as was
his right decades working to put enough
conservative Justice on the Supreme
Court to overtone Roe v Wade now has
access to 1.6 billion dollars in dark
money to do more damage and from our
perspective and restrict more freedoms
as far as We Know
did he fall asleep there it's where he
was sleep talking now what Biden's nut
jobs want is conservative donors to live
under the same protest hell as Amy Coney
Barrett and Brett Kavanaugh still do
but the good news is Biden's words today
are just hot air signifying nothing this
bill would be dead in the water
and speaking of a waste of time Kamala
had nothing better to do today than
repeat a tired old lie about States like
Georgia and of course push for a federal
takeover of state election laws
laws that not far from here
banned drop boxes and restrict early
voting laws that states surpassing
making it illegal to give folks who
stand in line to vote food and water
undemocratic laws
Un-American laws
she's lying she's a liar the truth is
George's election Integrity act
demagogue by charlatans like Kamala as
an act of some type of voter suppression
that law actually increased voting by
the most significant margin ever during
this last primary season in Georgia
and the idiots there lost the state the
Major League Baseball you know All-Star
game for nothing
thanks
so the closer we get to election day the
more desperate they're going to become
expect more anti-American propaganda
more interviews with Liz Cheney and
profiles of her expect the regime media
to hide what's happening to your streets
to your schools to your standard of
living
expect more leaks more investigations
lawsuits and threats to punish any
Republicans who speak up and speak out
don't be distracted you're too smart for
that stay focused on the real issue
what's best for your kids and your
country
we have a great opportunity this fall so
let's take advantage of it and that's
the angle hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else